what are the goals and Ambitions that
you're bringing to this tournament
um finish the tournament alive with a
pulse and actually I'd be happy to go
plus one that's what modest goal but you
know pretty realistic I'm the oldest guy
in the tournament
um
and I mean I've been preparing more
physically than mental than chess wise
nowadays I get a little bored
going over variations and stuff I get
more of a
a hit from you know doing physical stuff
uh you know for professional chess
player uh the goal is to play I mean the
best what you can do actually to show
your best chess and not to think too
much about the result to play well
because this year the tournament will be
extremely strong
probably
the strongest tournament uh Senior
tournament
compared to previous years I try not to
think about the result because usually
this is something which usually has
negative effect on my performance
also I learned from a lot of
professional athletes they always say
one game at the time and that's going to
be my Approach I am mainly trying not to
embarrass myself like I said I'm you
know just as really you know love of my
life but it's certainly not something
that I spend too much time in the last
20 years so I'm just hoping to have a
good fun and I'm in good time and as
they ignite some old friendships and
hopefully like I said you know had some
decent score since I'm like a regional
Champion I think the goal stays the same
you know to win it like but the
competition is getting stronger every
year and I'm getting older so we'll see
how it goes well it's only like to win
first first place
um it's a very prestigious tournament
it's drawing the best players I was able
to win this tournament in
2020 but that was uh covid year we
played online so it's not quite the same
thing to be you know winning it here in
the presence of all the other players so
I'd like to to be able to win one of
these tournaments in person you know
I've been uh busy for a while used to
play professional chess all the time so
now I'm just getting back into it so I'm
just going to really thoroughly enjoy
playing here I I mean I last last time I
played I started horrendously but then I
won the last three games which I guess
gives me the biggest winning streak of
anyone here so I hope to at least
reverse the trend may you know start
with wins and maybe uh and maybe not do
so many losses at the end
my goals are very modest these days
because of my age and stuff I'm more
care about results of my students and
one of my great students is play here
it's early sleep it's been for wonderful
years to be a song watching her and
she's very strong she's a very strong
player I'm watching her results and
growing up is great and myself of course
I would like want to play well but I'm
not a favorite
[Music]
foreign